you ever wonder why you never see much
of Joe Biden it's because he's only
working part-time the New York Times was
trying to do a little puff piece to show
how their dear leader has striking
stamina despite getting sandbagged all
the time but while trying to boost up
the big guy they also revealed how
pathetically weak his schedule is quote
in private some officials acknowledge
that they make what they consider
reasonable accommodations not to
physically tax an aging president his
staff schedules most of his public
appearances between noon and four and
leaves them alone on weekends as much as
possible and as the media tries to get
Biden over the Finish Line it sounds
like his friends in the intelligence
Community are up to something too
do you intend to vote for him again or
is there anyone on the Republican side
you might consider if it's not true
to be Joe Biden
and and I'm glad he's willing to serve
the president must be someone who abides
the law in our Constitution and there's
no one else but Joe Biden
all right Jessica uh
this is a grueling schedule
we got weekends off and don't bother me
before 10 A.M
and it's a lid at four
the article did note that the morning
schedule is actually similar to what
Barack Obama did who no one ever accused
of not being busy but he has did you see
Barack Obama's lazy I most certainly did
not that's something a republican would
say but that Barack Obama had doubled
the amount of evening events so things
that happened after the 4 P.M I I don't
know why it was
just something that was a puff piece I
thought it was a hit piece frankly I
don't think any Democrat who read that
thought this is good for us that this is
fair to an Administration who we largely
feel has accomplished a lot whether you
want Joe Biden to be the nominee again
in 2024 or not there are slew of things
that he got done and for that to come
out the week after the debt ceiling uh
negotiation where Kevin McCarthy came
out and said he was smart professional
and worked really hard and that jobs
report on Friday which went beyond
everyone's expectations and then you
wake up Monday morning and you see the
guy is napping all the time and we don't
want to bug him on a Saturday it came
out because he tripped on stage
everyone who is an honest broker so
you're I'm an exception to what I'm
about to say that you would anyone could
have tripped over that and it is
obviously painful to see an 80 year old
person sure do though I felt like it's
not like the man can't walk straight no
I mean he just can't walk upstairs
either yeah or yeah up on Air Force One
don't make me Ronald Reagan the panel
again yeah but didn't he also hit his
head the same day at Marine One you know
the day that he fell down look here's
the thing it was a pup piece and I I got
to tell you the thing that stopped me
when I was reading it was he has
striking stamina he took a nine hour
train ride
give me a break a nine hour train ride
boy that's tough stuff but you know what
and the the amazing part of it is when
you think about leaders you think about
leaders who get there because they
fought their way to the top and we all
look up to them and then there's always
this internal party you know competition
and then you've got a president here who
is he's he's he's not being challenged
by his own party because everybody's
like to leave them alone we don't want
anybody we don't want them to have to
come out on the campaign Trail because
you know we don't want to have to clean
up with all those statements that we did
every time he came out and spoke to the
Press but what about on the
international uh level I mean the the
the truth is that people in other
countries are looking at this man and
saying this is a joke he's running for
president he's not campaigning he
announced weeks ago he doesn't have a
primary because they stopped it and the
guy is you know he's at his beach house
I mean everybody is not dealing with the
reality and you know Ronald Reagan is
you know he was what 73. they're not
dealing with the reality here that this
guy has a lot of trouble a lot of the
time whether it's walking or talking or
stumbling away at a press conference or
where was he when he was he was supposed
to take a football helmet along with
something else and he just walked away
with one item when he was supposed to
take three which wasn't Jesse he's
always doing that do you think that he
even should worry because you got Comey
out there former head of the FBI Greg
basically says you know what we're going
to keep this guy in office you know
what's with him in sand Right Strips on
a sandbag then he goes to his beach
house
hard time Joe part-time Joe is a good
thing he shouldn't be at work in that
condition I respect him for his 50 years
of service but with his issues it's
better not to stress him out too much
let him enjoy his Twilight years with
his family his medical condition comes
first
um and I think it's cruel to make
somebody in that state work that hard
and I'm saying that with you know
artificial compassion but I say it with
compassion by the way I did you notice
Jack Dorsey endorsed RFK Jr right and
everybody keeps saying oh he's not like
he's not a serious candidate oh you
better believe he's a serious candidate
he's too serious to be taken seriously
do you know do you know what do you know
what his son did do you know what his
son did nobody talks about this oh he
went to his son joined the Foreign
Legion to fight the Russians on behalf
of Ukraine that makes RFK Jr the most
credible and persuasive voice on ending
this war which he declared he would do
which puts me in his camp and his son
went there to fight so he has he doesn't
just have skin in this game he's got
blood in this game well Joe's son got
involved in other foreign
tell us about your thoughts about
everything I was just thinking I might
start a new show on Fox Nation called
Puff piece or hit piece and then we'll
dissect the article that's because you
know Hillary Clinton believed that the
New York Times was awful to her to this
day she can't stand the New York Times
we look at the New York Times and be
like wow they're so easy on the
Democrats I bet the White House hated
that piece but they knew the piece was
coming but the piece was not pitched by
Republican opposition research it was
pitched by democrats who are granted
anonymity in the New York Times which
means that they were at a high enough
level that the New York Times thought
they were credible enough and their
quotes are things like it's all we can
talk about is how old he is we don't
know what's going to happen we call
several times a day just to check on his
health we don't know what's gonna and
they're so worried and so it's not
coming from the Republic the call is
coming from inside the house you know he
if you look at the schedule I'll never
forget the brunch lid until 5 PM I was
like Wow who is that that's that's some
boozy brunch there's there are no
campaign events no messaging strategy
there are no surrogates you said there
were going to be surrogates where the
surrogates you know what if Comey is
your surrogate that is a problem but
they're not giving him anything to work
on I did talk to a Democrat today who
said we know it's a challenge but just
from this
highly credible Democrat from media so
you hear what they want to do they want
they plan to try to show you that the
accomplishments Jessica's talking about
are having a direct impact on your life
okay so they're going to say oh aren't
you happy you have the infrastructure
Bill aren't you glad that the debt
ceiling was raised are you glad about
the uh I don't know I can't even think
of the third one oh it can't be student
loans because that's not going to happen
they want to have a more out on the
trail more I'm like well but that
doesn't work if he's actually not out on
the campaign Trail the third thing is
and this is the one that the Republicans
are just going to have to deal with
because the media will help them is that
they're going to try to take any concern
about his age to pale in comparison to
the toxicity of the Republican party and
whoever the eventual nominee is so
that's their Camp that's the I may be
old but he's toxic is that what it is
yeah okay yep can I say something
quickly about RFK
junior junior
to be clear if you are a serious
Democratic candidate you are not hanging
out in a Twitter space with Elon Musk
and Tulsi gabbard why because that is
not who we want to hear from it's not
who we respect and it's not who aligns
with our principles
Elon Musk is making the world go
electricity the fact that all
Republicans are defending him and I know
come on it's so agitated no talk about
the issues
if you watch this show there's a problem
I watch the show I live this show yeah
and I know there's no problem with me
and I'm telling you honestly about
what's going on in the Democratic party
we will respectfully disagree there's no
respect I can feel it yeah on either
side right now but I am correct
[Laughter]
you sound like me
I went on Brian Kilmeade I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
CK tie to the Fox News
it's the only way that I know for sure
that you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now